of course let me just start by saying uh
I thought you guys were fantastic in
this uh movie is so good
um thank you uh Jay I have to start with
an individual question for you um what
was it like not playing the person who
is a uh was obsessed with hockey yeah
crazy yeah or movies really uh um yeah
uh you know it was kind of refreshing it
was nice to see how the rest of the
world lives
um to to to to be in a world where I
didn't know hockey or movies were
important
um yeah
um but they also I have to say these
filmmakers were very uh were very very
respectful of me
um for anybody who cares you know the
scene in the diner with Carrie elways uh
or where you know Jim's watching hockey
and I'm almost certain the uh the
Canadians beat the Leafs on TV in that
game so uh they they previously picked a
clip for me so um yeah Glenn I have to
ask you are you are you a hockey fan in
general or no
um I like I mean I think it's an
interesting sport uh uh uh I think if uh
probably if I maybe if I lived in Canada
I'd be but I don't know I look I'm not
the truth is I'm not a sports fan in
general
um I prefer to play them than watch them
I was going to say I'm just curious of
the two of you uh who do you think's
winning the Cup this year
or maybe that's a chain question
that's definitely a j question oh frigg
you know at this point it's kind of
anybody like I I I know I think
everybody that was favored is
out of it already so
um and uh Florida Panthers might
it's crazy it's yeah I know horrible you
know yeah I was rooting uh I'm a Bruins
fan I was hoping the Brewers yeah dude
literally the the best year of any
hockey team ever in the regular season
in NHL history to go out in the
first it's crazy yeah I'm sorry I'm
sorry yeah I basically said it's long
yeah I can't anyway the point is it's
it's a I don't know who's gonna win um
Glenn I have to know what it was like
for you the day you decided to shave
your head to get to do this and what was
it like leaving like your apartment or
wherever you were and going to like a
supermarket or a Starbucks with that
look and you know and what was it like
for you yeah okay
so I was surprised at how I felt after
uh I shaved the top of my head
um I didn't realize how much of my
I guess my identity was wrapped up in
the fact that I have a full head of hair
uh it's like I didn't
I didn't like my nickname my nickname in
high school was curls because I had like
curly hair so like when people would
talk about me like in some of my most
formative years it was it was often
about like how much hair I had
so uh so
um you know it really kind of stripped
me of that part of my identity in a
really interesting way
um and but when I when I would go out uh
on the town as Glenn
uh I would always wear a hat and the
reason is not because I actually got to
a point where I actually kind of liked
the way it looked so maybe a strange
thing to say but I truly actually was
like I don't know it was it was
liberating and it was I I just kind of
liked I kind of liked it
but I was a little worried about going
out in public being bald not because I
cared if people saw me and were like oh
that's a bald guy I didn't care about
that because I I thought it looked kind
of good what I what I did care about was
if people recognized me and thought Oh I
didn't realize that guy there's a wig
you know I didn't want people to think
that like I usually wear a wig like that
that actually that actually makes me
happy
that makes complete sense yeah but I
also I also get it also people could
think that this is a bit for it's always
sunny or something well that's true
that's true but but you know but you
know how the internet works and be like
I saw Glenn Howerton he did you know
that he's really bald and then we I'd be
doing this interview with you right now
and people be like God that wig yeah
it's a pretty good piece
listen you never know how a movie is
gonna you make a movie in a void and you
never know how people are going to react
to it so what has it been like for the
two of you because this isn't like some
Marvel movie with crazy money to have
such positive reviews playing Itself by
playing at Berlin I mean like what is it
like for both of you to be part of
something that clearly is resonating the
best it's spectacular yeah I mean Jay's
had the Good Fortune of being involved
in really great television projects and
and film projects uh and I I've been a a
part of a few films here and there but
really haven't had much of a career in
the world of film so
um to finally get such a juicy juicy
role in something and then actually
people are watching it and enjoying it
is as an actor who's always been a huge
film buff and somebody who loves
watching films and and just obsessed
with films
um it's incredibly incredibly gratifying
uh the response to the film and the fact
that people are really talking about it
and seeing it um it's uh it's really
exciting yeah it's it's really special
you know like I I for me I really just
want to leave it knowing that we did
something cool you know and and and and
I knew that we made something special I
was convinced of that like in the first
week I was like oh the the process and
US jamming like the these are we're
making good songs man no no B sides like
this is this is the best
um but you know I I have no idea
what people like I I you know and if and
if like the past sort of half decade has
taught me anything it's that like I
don't understand the world or people or
their interests or their tastes or
anything you know and especially in an
era where there's basically you know uh
a movie about like four people stuck in
a house
um or Harry Potter and James Bond in
Star Wars and nothing in between I just
like you never know what people's
appetites are like and if you know so
this is all to say that it's the best
it's nice to see that people dig it as
much as we do you know that that's
that's the coolest thing in the world
yeah the thing I was wondering and I was
going to ask Matt this but he's not here
is that this is one of those like crazy
stories that at any point where you like
how like you know uh having like a big
Studio or someone come in and tell the
story be before you guys could almost
tell it if that makes any sense like
were you oh were we worried that we were
onto something so cool and it was a
matter of time before someone else told
the story is that kind of yeah
um they might have been I was like
because it all because most of the story
happened in Kitchener Waterloo I
didn't assume that that anybody was on
our trip I thought we had some I thought
we had some time I thought we had some
time yeah
you know what it is what what if what a
total diss too like that
somebody had didn't beat us to it in a
way you know what I mean it's like a
weird Canadian diss like you know I
because I feel like I feel like if if
this was an American company that
probably would have would have happened
and that's kind of messed up yeah that's
not that's not wrong actually there be
there would be competing Blackberry
projects if it was down here
their Hollywood good at is hearing that
someone is making something and then
thinking oh that's a good idea we should
also do that yeah yeah yeah I I think
people have kind of I I think it also
speaks to the sort of
um Collective selective memory or
selective Amnesia that the modern world
has about this device and this
Corporation I think you know
um iPhone kind of makes you forget that
there was anything before it you know
and so I think that's also part of part
of why uh this is like a kind of great
untold story but it's so many so many
Blackberry obsessives are coming out of
the Woodworks and and are so excited
about this movie because they were so
obsessed with their Blackberry device
yeah I mean in the movie you talk about
it being a crackberry and I remember
people calling it a crackberry I I
remember the obsessive you know um and
listen I'm sure you've been asked this a
thousand times and I apologize but did
either of you have one
um and did you enjoy it wouldn't it be
crazy if you're like whoa you
know what's crazy nobody ever asked that
um
no uh I had one I had uh almost every
iteration from whenever I started
circa040506 I guess until about two
years ago I literally got rid of one two
years ago
um so I was I went I went down with the
ship uh in in a large way I I adored
that machine I miss it I never I never
had one I I could never uh wrap my head
around uh
how to get my thumbs to work on those
little teeny tiny buttons I I just and
you didn't want people to get a hold of
you
to want my yeah I also for the most part
just always want to be left alone so
like that the Blackberry was kind of my
worst nightmare this is a sidebar
question but both of you have done uh
cool work and a number of things if
someone is actually if someone has
actually never seen anything you've done
before what is the first thing you want
them watching and why oh damn
bro that's a heavy question I've
literally never that's actually like
that's a heavy one no one's ever asked
there's oh wow uh
there's a few things I'm very very proud
of uh but
few that I'm more proud of than this
film
and if people watched this at this and
this was their introduction to me as an
actor I would be stoked
um yeah I I would feel the same way if
if like you know
um but I guess uh yeah also I'd have to
say the the two goon movies I think uh
you know I'm I'm not in them a ton but
you know I co-wrote them and directed
the second one and they are like as
close to my world view as ever but have
been put on screen so I think that would
be the kind of that that'd be a good uh
an entry point I'd just be interested
that somebody was psyched to like that
somebody was like Googling me and being
like who's it what else did he do you
know like God if someone went down to
like Frederick March rabbit hole but for
me I would be very very I I went down a
Frederick March Wikipedia Rabbit Hole
recently so anyway yeah so that's it go
go you know what me okay go go
look at some Old Frederick March movies
it's also shocking that the thing you're
recommending has to do with hockey
what's that oh yes yes yes I know crazy
crazy right so you guys obviously did a
lot of research when you were getting
ready for these roles what was like some
of the things that you learned about
Blackberry or your characters that
really surprised you I guess
um good question I I the thing that
surprised me was not a thing about uh
Mike lazzarita specifically so much as
the great kind of uh uh Research In
Motion
um adventure and misadventure which was
I didn't know about the American kind of
government like Stock Exchange
Commission like I didn't know that those
guys came up to Canada with warrants and
stuff and I and I didn't know that
um about the like Verizon cell tower
hijacking stuff like all of that really
crazy fog of War I didn't know any
of it yeah I didn't you know any of the
story at all so it was all a bit of a
surprise to me but you know within the
context of that yeah the
some of the the hacking of the Verizon
towers thing like Jay said that that was
crazy that seems insane that seems
insane to me crazy also just like when
it's being pitched to Mike hey we can
hack these towers uh and the way it's
pitched is like oh yeah we we hacked
into you know Sony PlayStation sister
like yeah like these that these guys
just like hack into these systems to
like get what they want it just seems uh
insane to me like I mean some of the
things that these guys did you know the
fact that the fact that uh uh that
you know Jim was told you can't sell any
more phones because it's gonna it's
gonna completely like destroy the
network and he was like oh really and
then just goes immediately watch me and
then just goes immediately to his uh
sales team and is like I need you to
sell a million black blackheads
like
it's like that's
and then and then just to come up and
then just to basically you know
Blindside his Tech team with like you
gotta this is happening so you got to
deal with it you got to figure this out
like just figure it out uh I'm almost
out of time but uh what's a scene in the
film that you got on the first take or a
scene that you thought would be easy
that ended up being a real pain in the
ass
um well we didn't there are no first
takes because Matt Johnson
um you know has he suffers the disease
of perfectionism like he he's a he's a
he's a bit of a mini Kubrick in that
respect like if it were up to him we'd
still be shooting in that
Warehouse
so so uh and uh it all reads relatively
easy because it's all just guys standing
and talking
um
but it's and the way that they
shoot is crazy right like the cameras
are always you know on the other side of
the room we never knew where they were
they were and they're shooting on these
big off like National Geographic
lenses and and so we just didn't know
like so there is a sort of
there is a chaos that we weren't privy
to the the math the code wasn't told to
us we were just like kind of active act
and just and but with no we never ever
knew how close we were to getting a
scene like we like I I we kept asking
each other Glenn and I would often like
you I feels like we've got this like
what the is happening and so we
were just kind of like Out on the Ocean
and Matt was the only one who knew where
we were going yeah I mean it was it was
uh it was a really interesting process
like usually you've got a bunch of
lights and cameras like right in your
face
um you know and you get used to that uh
and it's not a problem but with this the
cameras were always so far like like Jay
said we did we half the time most of the
time most of the time we did not know
where the cameras were so every take
felt like a rehearsal and there was
something kind of liberating about it
yeah you know um and and fun about that
but uh yeah I don't know it was it was
it was a very interesting it was very
interesting process
um you know I I remember having a tough
time with that that scene where I had to
go in and tell the sales guy to sell a
million blackberries I don't know why
but for some reason that that scene was
giving us problems but I mean it's not
doesn't really make a good story because
I don't I don't even remember I just
remember it was the only time on set
where I felt like I was doing what I was
supposed to be doing and Matt and Matt
was like no this you're not getting this
that didn't really happen all that often
and you know
he's a really great he's a really great
way of of being very blunt and honest
about things but without being uh
without being rude you know without
being like mean or cruel but if you
weren't getting it he was going to tell
you and he and you were going to be
there until we got it yeah that's
absolutely yeah the scene when I when he
when him and I are practicing in my
first talked to Jim on the phone of like
how we're gonna negotiate you know
um like Matt and I got into a full-on
argument that had that like we he like
cleared the set for half an hour so that
he and I could hash this out
um and so like because but all and
through nobody's fault there was no bad
guy in that situation it was just like
um it is the best thing to work with
somebody that has you know a really kind
of clear voice and and who just wants to
create and wants it to be as good as it
can be there's a difference between that
and somebody who is just shooting
because they don't know what it is
they're looking for and they hope the
entire kind of cast and crew will just
like show it to them and they keep
waiting for that moment without knowing
what that moment looks like and MJ is
not that
um MJ is specific and definitive
um but yeah if if you're not there if
you're not in the movie that he sees in
his heart
um you're gonna be there until you do
you know
um and like you know literally the the
movie that came out at Berlin is
slightly different than the movie that
played at South by is slightly different
than the movie that's going to come out
this week like he he has edited he cut
until they literally physically told him
he can't anymore like he cut after both
festivals he kept going back to it like
there's like all he does is make movies
that's all he wants to be doing and
that's the best thing in the world
however sometimes on like hour 12 of a
day as an actor and you've got a wig or
a shaved head and it's 40
degrees Celsius and a dare like steel
facility in Hamilton you're like buddy
like off
uh I have to stop with you guys but I'm
so curious of what he changed from South
by to Berlin to what I saw or is it just
like a tiny little thing there it's I
experientially I don't know that even
Glenn or I would ever notice it right
now lots of tinkering just little little
things no no big no big sweeping changes
like the cut that's going to come out is
the average person would never be able
to watch them back to back you know the
Berlin cut and the the theatrical cut
and be able to tell the difference yeah
there's no story changes yeah it is all
yeah it's Just Vibe
I totally get it it's like cutting a
little bit of like a little breath from
a scene or whatever it's like a slight
tweak oh listen guys I just want to
thank you for your time and seriously
you both did so great in this and um I
really hope it's a huge hit uh good luck
with the rest of the speed dating
thank you thanks so much